I first met her on the set of National
Velvet we were both quite young but even
then I knew that we were dealing with
someone very special and time has proven
me right but special was perhaps an
underestimation for what she turned out
to be is unique starting with the eyes
have there ever been like that I mean
they really are violent and if the eyes
are the mirror of the soul then that is
where we should look to appreciate the
essence of this woman those eyes have
shed tears for the loss of life from
aids of both those achingly close to her
and total strangers caught in the throes
of this devastating illness and those
eyes have also registered hope and
determination to inspire others to
mobilize for medical research and
patient care Elizabeth was one of the
very first to take up the cause when it
wasn't politically correct and she has
never wavered in her vision of a world
free from this horrible scourge through
her dedicated work from for alpha and
for the Elizabeth Taylor foundation for
patient care she is more than a symbol
she is a leader an activist and a
shining example of the use of celebrity
for the celebration of life many years
have passed since we first shared a
screen and I am most honored to share a
stage with her tonight if only for the
chance to look again into those
remarkable eyes and say the Academy
proudly presents the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award for service that has
brought credit to our industry to
Elizabeth Taylor
thank you so much I have been on this
stage many times as a presenter I have
sat in the audience as a loser and I've
had the thrill and the honor of standing
here as a winner but I never ever
thought I would come out here to receive
this award it is the highest possible
accolade I could receive from my peers
and for doing something I just have to
do that my passion must do I am filled
with pride and humility I accept this
award in honor of all the men women and
children with AIDS who are waging
incredibly valiant battles for their
lives those to whom I have given my
commitment the real heroes of the
pandemic of AIDS I am so proud of the
work that people in Hollywood have done
to help so many others like dearest
gentle Audrey and while she is I know in
heaven forever guarding her beloved
children I will remain here as rowdy and
activist as I have to be and God willing
for as long as I have to be tonight
tonight I am asking for your help I call
upon you to draw from the depths of your
being to prove that we are a human race
to prove that our love outweighs our
need to hate that our compassion is more
compelling that I need to blame that our
sensitivity those in need is stronger
than our greed that our ability to
reason overcomes our fear and that at
the end of each of our lives we can look
back and be proud that we have treated
others with the kindness dignity and
respect that every human being deserves
thank you and God bless